Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That had three ships and left from Spain. He sailed through sunshine, wind and rain. He sailed by night, he sailed by day, he used the stars to find his way. A compass also helped him know how to find the way to go. Ninety sailors were on board. Some men worked while others snored. Day after day they looked for land. They dreamed of trees and rocks and sand.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听特权，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。那艘船有三桅，自西班牙启航。他穿过阳光、风雨和风浪。他夜里航行，他白昼航行，他借助繁星指引方向。指南针也帮他知晓前行的方向。船上有九十名水手。有人劳作，有人鼾声如雷。日复一日，他们寻找着陆地。他们梦想着树木、岩石和沙滩。
October 12, their dream came true. You never saw a happier crew. Indians! Indians! Columbus cried. His heart was filled with joyful pride. But India, the land was not. It was the Bahamas. And it was hot. Columbus sailed on to find some gold to bring back home, as he'd been told. He made the trip again and again, trading gold to bring to Spain. The first American? No, not quite. But Columbus was brave and he was bright. So, Dominic, we on the rest of history, big fans of William McGonagall. Yes. But he is rivaled by Gene Mazzolo, who is apparently a bestselling US kids author from the 1970s onwards. Your notes tell me. Well, lots of our American listeners will be very familiar with that wonderful work of poetry time the bardic tradition at its best
10月12日，他们的梦想成真。你从未见过比这更快乐的船员。印第安人！印第安人！哥伦布大喊。他的心中充满了喜悦与自豪。但那并不是印度。那是巴哈马群岛。而且天气炎热。哥伦布继续航行，去寻找一些黄金带回老家，正如他被告知的那样。他一次又一次地进行航行，将黄金运回西班牙。第一个美洲人？不，算不上。但哥伦布勇敢而又聪慧。那么，多米尼克，我们这些《历史的余烬》的主播，都是威廉·麦戈纳格尔（William McGonagall）的超级粉丝。是的。但他遇到了对手吉恩·马佐洛（Gene Mazzolo），这位显然是20世纪70年代及以后美国最畅销的儿童文学作家。你的笔记告诉我的。嗯，我们的许多美国听众对那首精彩的诗歌一定非常熟悉，吟游诗人的传统在其间展现得淋漓尽致。
so um a great poem both for its command of rhyme and meter and all that kind of stuff but but also for its historical accuracy so as we've been describing um columbus wasn't necessarily trading was he when he got hold of gold yeah i think maybe well some a lot of academics now would probably use the word looting wouldn't they yes possibly or stealing and also that poem which lots of american listeners will have heard when they were elementary school there's no mention there of the fact that he was also taking back people um from the very beginning he was taking back people against their will so it's such an interesting debate and we'll come to it in the
所以，嗯，这是一首无论在押韵、格律还是其他方面都堪称精妙的伟大诗歌，但同时也是因为它在历史准确性上的表现。正如我们之前一直在描述的，嗯，哥伦布当他弄到黄金时，其实并不完全是在进行贸易，对吧？是的，我想也许，现在很多学者可能会用“掠夺”这个词，对吧？是的，可能是的，或者说是偷窃。而且，那首许多美国听众在小学时都听过的诗中，完全没有提到这样一个事实：他从一开始就在违背人们意愿的情况下，强行把人抓回欧洲。所以这是一个非常有趣的话题，我们将在
second half the sort of columbus hero or villain i mean whether history has heroes or villains is a rather issue which we'll also discuss but it's clearly columbus's legacy is a complicated one and and even at the time i mean we've already discussed this in previous episodes in this series even at the time people were arguing about columb. He was hated by a lot of the people who sailed with him, who fell out with him. There was the friar we talked about in the last episode, who basically went back to Spain and informed on him to the Catholic monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabella, said, you know, Columbus is a terrible man. He's behaving very badly. So arguments about Columbus are not, I mean, as you said last time, they're not 21st century arguments.
下半场讨论。关于哥伦布究竟是英雄还是恶棍，我的意思是，历史究竟有没有英雄或恶棍，这是一个相当经典的问题，我们接下来也会讨论。但显而易见的是，哥伦布的遗产极其复杂，而且即使在当时——我们在这个系列的之前的节目中其实已经讨论过了——甚至在当时，人们就对哥伦布争论不休。他被许多与他一起航行、并最终与他闹翻的人所恨之入极。正如我们在上一集节目中聊到的那个修士，他基本上回到了西班牙，并向天主教双王斐迪南和伊莎贝拉告发了他，说：“你知道，哥伦布是个可怕的人。他的行为极其恶劣。”所以关于哥伦布的争论，我的意思正如你上次所说，并不是21世纪才有的争论。
They're 16th century arguments that we're still having, basically. But we left last time on a bit of a, so Columbus had come back from voyage number two and was sort of hanging around Spain, desperate to go back for a third voyage, even though he's lost his monopoly. So other people are going over now. And the Catholic monarchs do eventually decide to let him go. But the plan is now that he will go beyond the Caribbean. He will see what else is there.
这些是16世纪的争论，直到今天我们还在进行。基本上就是这样。不过我们上期节目结束时留下的悬念是，哥伦布结束了第二次航海回国，当时正闲晃在西班牙，渴望着进行第三次航海，尽管他已经失去了垄断权。所以其他人现在也开始前去美洲了。而天主教双王最终还是决定让他出发。但现在的计划是，他要超越加勒比地区，去看看那里究竟还有什么。
Specifically, he's going south, isn't he? Yes. Because he's traveled to the Gold Coast on Africa. And it's an assumption of geographers of the time that if there's gold on one latitude, then it's going to be on one side of the Atlantic, then it'll be, there'll be gold on the other side as well. Yeah, that doesn't strike me as unimpeachable geography. I'm not a great geographer. So Columbus's relationship to geographical theory in this is interesting. So he heads southwards, and basically he's heading for the continent of south america and he almost gets there and then his supplies are running out and so he veers off north and he sees ahead of him
具体来说，他是要往南走，对吧？是的。因为他曾去过非洲的黄金海岸。当时地理学家有一个假设，既然某个纬度的一边大西洋有黄金，那么大西洋的另一边也应该有黄金。是的，这听起来不像是无可挑剔的地理学。我可不是什么伟大的地理学家。所以哥伦布对地理理论的关系在这里很有意思。因此他向南进发，基本上是朝南美洲大陆驶去，几乎就要抵达了，但这时他的补给耗尽了，于是他转向北方，看见前方
an island with three mountains and so he calls it after the trinity trinidad so trinidad yes he does indeed he's actually what you missed out on was before he got to trinidad so this is 1498 he stopped in what's called the doldrums. So the doldrums is this spot where basically there's no wind. And wine turns to vinegar, doesn't it? Yeah. And it's incredibly hot and you'll just be calm there. And actually, I know you're a big fan. You're starting to get into the novels of Patrick O'Brien. And there's a very, very memorable sequence in those stories, which are about the age of the Napoleonic Wars and a sea captain and his friend, Aubrey and Maturin, in the Napoleonic Wars. There's a very
有一座岛屿上有三座山峰，于是他以三位一体（Trinity）为它命名——特立尼达（Trinidad）。所以，特立尼达，是的，他确实这么做了。实际上，你漏掉了一点，那就是在他到达特立尼达之前——这是在1498年——他在一个被称为无风带（doldrums）的地方停了下来。无风带就是这样一个地方，基本上没有任何风。酒都变成醋了，对吧？是的。而且热得难以置信，你会一动不动地困在那里。实际上，我知道你是帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brien）小说的超级粉丝。你开始涉猎他的小说了。在那些以拿破仑战争时代为背景、讲述一位海难船长和他的朋友奥布莱恩与马蒂兰（Aubrey and Maturin）故事的小说里，有一个非常、非常令人难忘的桥段。那是
memorable passage when they are stuck in the doldrums and it's incredibly hot. They have no water and they can't move. You're waiting desperately for a breath of wind. And this is exactly what happens to Columbus. And this is why he has to go north, because they're running out of supplies. Exactly. So he goes to Trinidad, but then he does make the crossing across the Caribbean. It's a very perilous, difficult crossing. But he's a brilliant mariner, isn't he? I mean, this is the thing. So there is madness, but there is also method. Yes. So his ability to, there's almost a kind of supernatural quality to his ability to find ways across seas that no European is there in the most horrendous conditions often and he's heading for venezuela so he is going to somewhere where no european has ever been again
一个极其难忘的片段，描写他们被困在无风带中，天气热得难以忍受。他们没有淡水，也无法动弹。你只能绝望地等待一丝微风。而这正是哥伦布所遭遇的情况。这也是为什么他必须向北走，因为他们的补给快用完了。没错。所以他去了特立尼达，但他确实完成了穿越南加勒比海的航行。那是一次极其危险、艰难的航行。但他是一位出色的航海家，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是关键所在。因此，其中既有疯狂，也有章法。是的。所以他的这种能力，他的这种寻路能力几乎有一种超自然的特质，能在最可怕的条件下，带领大家穿越连任何欧洲人都未曾涉足的海洋，而且他正驶向委内瑞拉——也就是说，他正前往一个连任何欧洲人都从未去过的地方。
and he hears this great what he describes as a deafening roar like the noise of an enormous wave crashing against rocks and currents going from east to west with all the mighty fury of the Guadalquivir in full flow. The Guadalquivir is the river Seville. And this is the estuary of the river Orinoco. And it was a gigantic estuary, bigger than anything any European will ever have seen. And Columbus writes later that he says, I can still feel the fear spreading through my veins that I felt with the thought that we're in danger of capsizing, faced with this kind of torrent of water. And it's funny, there's a funny moment. They anchor near the estuary and they raise a cross on the land.
接着，他听到了那种巨大的、他所形容震耳欲聋的轰鸣声，就像巨浪撞击礁石的巨响，洋流由东向西奔流，带着瓜达尔基维尔河（Guadalquivir）全满时的磅礴怒涛。瓜达尔基维尔河就是塞维利亚的河流。而这里正是奥里诺科河（Orinoco）的河口。这是一个巨大的河口，比任何欧洲人以前见过的都要宏大。哥伦布后来写道，他说：“我依然能感到恐惧在我的血管中蔓延，那种当我想到面对这种洪流般的汹涌水势，我们随时有覆船危险时的恐惧。”说来有趣，还有一个有趣的时刻。他们在河口附近抛锚，并在岸上竖起了一座十字架。
The admiral asked the pilots where they thought they were. And some said they thought they were in the Sea of Spain, others in the Sea of Scotland. Yes. Well, it's a the Sea of Scotland. Yes. Well, it's a bit hotter than Scotland. Yes. Well, but Columbus himself, I mean, he's torn in all kinds of ways as to where he might be because he's still very much clinging to the idea that he's reached Asia.
海军上将问领航员他们认为自己身在何处。有人说他们觉得自己在大海里，即西班牙之海，另一些人则认为在苏格兰之海。是的。嗯，这是苏格兰之海。是的。嗯，那里比苏格兰要热一些。是的。不过哥伦布本人，我的意思是他对于自己究竟身在何处感到极其纠结，因为他仍然非常执着于自己已经抵达亚洲的想法。
He's not abandoning that hope. But he is also perhaps in the nether reaches of his mind starting to contemplate the possibility that, as he puts it himself, that he is navigating along a very large continent, which has hitherto remained unknown. So that's a kind of shadow over his thoughts. And then there is a wilder, more apocalyptic, kind of religiously infused perspective that is also part of his thinking all the time. And he's starting to think, well, maybe this is Eden. Yeah, it's crazy, isn't it?
他并没有放弃这个希望。但与此同时，在他的内心深处，他也开始思索这样一种可能性：正如他自己所说的那样，他正在沿着一块非常巨大的大陆航行，而这块大陆迄今为止仍然不为人知。所以这在他的脑海中投下了一种阴影。然后还有一种更加狂野、更具末世色彩、充满宗教色彩的视角，这也一直贯穿着他的思想。他开始想，嗯，也许这就是伊甸园。是的，这太疯狂了，不是吗？
I think nothing better exemplifies the genius and the weirdness of Columbus than the fact that he, as he's been sailing, he's noticed things about the stars. And because of his observation of the stars and the fact that they are not behaving as they should do were the globe to be perfectly spherical a perfect sphere he comes to think you know is he sailing uphill yeah um and he starts to construct this image of the globe as being in the shape of a pair yes or even better and this is very much an idea that you could see he's been at sea a very long time um surrounded entirely by men it is as if somebody had a very round ball and somewhere on its surface, it was as if a woman's breast had been placed there.
我想没有什么比这更能体现哥伦布的天才与古怪了：他在航行时注意到了一些关于星星的现象。正因为他对群星的观察，以及如果地球是一个完美的球体，星星本不该有那样的运行轨迹，他开始思考：难道他是在“上坡”航行吗？是的，嗯……他开始将地球构建成一个像梨子一样的形状，或者更好的比喻——你可以看出他在海上呆了太久了，周围完全都是男人——这就好像有人拿了一个非常圆的球，在它表面的某一个地方，安放了一个女性的乳房。
So that the point at which we might imagine the nipple would be is the most prominent part and the nearest to the heavens. So he's casting the nipple as Eden. But in fact, he's right. The world isn't a perfect sphere. So he's onto something. On the other hand, the world is not shaped quite as he is describing it. On the other hand, the world is not a breast shaped like a breast. So there's a lot going
因此，我们可以想象乳头所在的那个点，就是最突出的部分，也是最接近天堂的地方。所以他把乳头比作伊甸园。但事实上，他是对的。世界并不是一个完美的球体。所以他确实发现了一些端倪。另一方面，世界的外形并不像他所描述的那样。另一方面，世界并不是一个乳房形状的乳房。所以很显然，这里面有很多
on there, obviously. Yeah, he has been at sea too long, I think it's fair to say. But wouldn't you say, I mean, that's kind of paradigmatically Christopher Columbus' behavior? It's the combination of a slightly fevered mind. He has been at sea too long. His paranoia, his anxiety about the fact that his theory isn't matching the facts. I mean, that's been a feature right from that very first voyage in 1492, but also the intense religiosity. That's been a feature of Columbus's life from the very beginning. He is incredibly pious. I think he has started to really believe that he has been chosen by destiny. So in episode one, we were talking about when he was setting out, he thought of himself as somebody... We had that sort of line about him being the teenager in their
复杂的心理活动。是的，我想说句公道话，他在海上待得太久了。但你不觉得吗，这其实是克里斯托弗·哥伦布式的典型行为？这是他那种略显狂热的心态的结合体。他在海上呆得太久了。他的偏执，他对自己的理论与现实不符的焦虑。我的意思是，这从1492年的那次最初航行开始就是一个特点，但同时还有那种强烈的宗教狂热。这从一开始就是哥伦布人生的一个特点。他极其虔诚。我想他已经开始真正相信自己是被命运选中之人。所以在第一集中，我们在谈到他启程时，他把自己看作是一个……我们当时有过那样的比喻，说他就像是一个在卧室里读着网络论坛、满脑子各种理论的少年。但到了现在，大约1498年左右，这种心态已经变得强迫性、病态地强迫性，以至于他认为所有其他人都错了，只有他拥有这种独特的、神圣注定的使命，他开始透过这个棱镜来看待一切，而且我认为——难道你不觉得从这个时候起，他成了一个略显忧郁、孤立的形象吗？绝对是的，而且还有身体上的衰退，对吧？因为他的眼睛开始痛了。是的，所以他处于那种困惑、迷雾之中，他甚至不知道委内瑞拉是什么。他不知道奥里诺科河是什么。
bedroom, reading internet forums and coming up with theories and whatnot. But by now, 1498 or so, that has become obsessive, unhealthily obsessive, to the extent that he thinks everybody else is wrong, that he has this unique, divinely ordained destiny, and he starts to see everything through that prism and i he he don't you think he cuts a slightly melancholy isolated figure from this point on definitely and also there's physical decline isn't there because his eyes are starting to hurt yes so he's sort of so that that confusion that fog that he is in he doesn doesn't know what Venezuela is. He doesn't know what the Orinoco is.
他以为自己可能身处天堂或伊甸园之类的地方。或者是中国。或者是中国，正如你所说。我的意思是，这与另一个事实相呼应：由于他在古巴似乎染上了一种眼疾，导致他实际上已经看不见了。而且这种眼疾越来越严重，部分原因就是这个眼疾病情。我的意思是，他本可以继续深入委内瑞拉。事实上，如果他真的继续前行，我怀疑他可能会死在那里，因为那些跋涉穿过委内瑞拉丛林的征服者的故事……是的。
He thinks he might be in paradise or Eden or whatever. Or China. Or China, as you say. I mean, that's mirrored by the fact that he actually can't see because he has this eye condition that he seems to have come down with in Cuba. And it's sort of getting worse and worse, partly because of the eye condition. I mean, he could have gone on into Venezuela. Actually, if he had gone on, I wonder if he'd probably have died because the story of conquistadors who go trudging through the jungles of Venezuela. Yeah.
我的意思是，那些故事通常以极其悲惨的结局告终，比如人相食、被野兽吃掉、死于疟击。非常像沃纳·赫尔佐格（Werner Herzog）的电影。非常像沃纳·赫尔佐格，没错。但事实上，由于他的眼睛出了问题，加之他感觉身体极度不适，他决定返回伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，他也确实这么做了。他回到了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。按照惯例，他到达时发现之前被他留在那里的人要么已经死了，要么彼此之间闹得不可开交。他的兄弟巴托洛梅奥（Bartolomeo）跟一个叫弗朗西斯科·罗尔丹（Francisco Roldan）的家伙闹翻了。罗尔丹已经彻底背叛了哥伦布式的统治体制。
I mean, those stories normally end extremely badly with them eating each other, being eaten, dying of malaria. Very Werner Herzog. Very Werner Herzog, exactly. But actually, because of his eyes and because he's feeling so ropey, he decides to go back to Hispaniola, which he does. He goes back to Hispaniola. And as is the tradition, he arrives to find that all the men who he'd left there previously have either died or fallen out massively with each other. His brother, Bartolomeo, has fallen out with this guy called Francisco Roldan. Roldan has turned completely against the sort of Columbus regime.
这里面充斥着各种非常复杂、甚至有点让人难以捉摸的争论，涉及土地所有权、对待当地人的方式等等。事件发生后，他们想出了一套新系统，这实际上预示了西班牙人日后不仅在加勒比地区、而且在墨西哥将要采取的很多做法，这个系统被称为“监护征赋制”（encomienda）。这种制度的运作方式是：你被授予一块土地，然后你会分到一个部落首领，他基本上是被指派给你的，而他的工作——我的意思是，他基本上从一个部落首领变成了一个工头。他的工作就是让手下所有人为你干活，而你则获得了这片土地。我的意思是，
There's all sorts of very complicated and slightly sort of impenetrable arguments about land ownership, treatments of the locals. They come up with a new system in the wake of this, which actually anticipates a lot of what the Spanish are going to do, not just in the Caribbean, but also in Mexico, which is called the encomienda. And the way that works is you're given a land grant, and then you're given a chieftain, basically, who's assigned to you and it's his job. I mean, he's basically been turned from a chieftain to a foreman. And his job is to get all his people to work for you. And you're granted this land. I mean,
这基本上就是西班牙人瓜分整个新世界的方式。到了那个时候，离哥伦布的第一次航行才仅仅过去六年，但整个事业的运作方式已经与葡萄牙人的系统完全不同了。如果葡萄牙人来做这件事，他们会建立几个贸易据点，然后就此作罢。但西班牙人——正如你上次所说的那样，因为收复失地运动（reconquista）的背景，他们习惯了征服土地的理念，习惯于在上面移民、建立农场和矿场，这其中包含着各种令人着迷的“如果”假设，不是吗？如果葡萄牙人来做这件事会怎样？是的，因为他们会继续劳作吗？他们会与现有的某种国家实体合作吗？换句话说，也就是与印加人合作？还会存在一个阿芝特克帝国吗？对，没错，完全是这样。葡萄牙人会继续利用
that's basically how the Spanish will divvy up the whole of the New World. And by that point, so it's only six years since Columbus's first voyage, but the whole enterprise has worked out completely different from the Portuguese system. So if the Portuguese had done it, they'd have established a few trading posts, and that's it. But the Spanish, because of what you were saying last time because the reconquista they're used to the idea of conquering land and sort of planting it with people and with farms and mines and all these kinds of fascinating what if isn't it if the portuguese had done it yeah because would they have continued working would they have worked with existing sort of state entities as it were so in other words with the incas would there still be an aztec right exactly yeah exactly would the portuguese have have carried on to have used
他们作为合作者并与之进行贸易，还是无论如何他们都会被疾病消灭？谁知道呢，还有欧洲人对土地的贪婪，对吧？随着时间的推移，这种贪婪是否会……确实如此。而且，当法国人或英国人在后来介入时，葡萄牙人真的有足够强大到能够维持并抵御他们吗？无论如何……这是关于哥伦布的经典案例：有些人想回家，他就让他们回家，但他带有那种近乎自杀式的倾向，允许他们带走奴隶，尽管他知道伊莎贝拉女王对此坚决反对。所以他们带走了奴隶。当他们回到西班牙时，女王对此感到非常恼火。
them as collaborators and traded with them or would they have been wiped out anyway by disease i mean who knows and european land greed yeah and over time would the exactly um and indeed would portugal have been strong enough to sustain defend off yeah other with the french let's say or the english when they when they got involved um later on anyway um it's the sort of classic thing with columbus some people want to go home he lets them go home but with that sort of suicidal side he says they can take slaves with them, even though he knows Queen Isabella is dead against this. So they take slaves back. And when they get back, the queen is very put out about this.
伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上还有更多的内讧。然后到了1500年，一个名叫博巴蒂利亚（Bobadilla）的家伙从西班牙抵达了。他实际上是被天主教双王斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的前任内侍派来的。他们说：够了够了。去伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，把这一切都收拾干净。是的，故事到此为止。哥伦布简直是一团糟。
There's loads more feuding on Hispaniola. And then in 1500, a guy arrives from Spain called Bobadilla. And he has actually been sent by the former Chamberlain to the Catholic monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabella. And they said, enough is enough. Go to Hispaniola, sort it all out. Yeah, end of story. Columbus is shambles.
哥伦布一直在那里，生病、发疯、痛苦不堪，无休止地写着关于大卫和所罗门以及诸如此类的事情。博巴蒂利亚出现了。是的，压力山大，一直在写关于大卫和所罗门以及诸如此类的事情。博巴蒂利亚出现了。是的，压力山大，完全如此。博巴蒂利亚出现了，实际上直接把他给逮捕了。他们见了个面，然后博巴蒂利亚就把他给锁上了链子。进展非常快，不是吗？
Columbus has been there, ill, mad, miserable, writing endlessly about David and Solomon and all this sort of business. Bobadilla turns up. Yeah, pressed, writing endlessly about David and Solomon and all this sort of business. Bobadilla turns up. Yeah, pressed, exactly. Bobadilla turns up and actually just arrests him. They have a meeting and then Bobadilla sort of claps him in chains. It's very fast, isn't it?
嗯，你知道，他这么做了，而且可能也确实该这么做。把他塞上一艘船，说道：滚回西班牙去。这基本上就宣告了哥伦布作为总督生涯的结束，也宣告了他作为一个管理型人物生涯的终结。所以他在1500年11月回到了西班牙。他越来越沉迷于这种宗教修辞。因此他写信给双王。他说：“巴巴迪亚（注：即博巴蒂利亚）把我锁着链子送到这里。
Well, you know, he did it and probably was right to do it. Puts him on a ship and says, back to Spain. And that's basically the end of Columbus as a governor, as the end of him as a sort of managerial figure. So he's back in Spain by November 1500. He's more and more going in for this kind of religious rhetoric. So he says, he writes to the monarchs. He says, Baba Dia sent me here in chains.
我发誓我不知道也想不出原因，除非是上帝我们的主希望我为殿下们做些什么。我所做的，仅仅是亚伯拉罕为以撒、摩西为在埃及的以色列人民所做的事。”这不是很神奇吗？他被锁着链子送回来，却在信中把自己比作亚伯拉罕和摩西，而现在居然还有第四次航行。他是如何说服斐迪南和伊莎贝拉支持他进行第四次航行的？因为我们一直在讨论他是个难缠的人、是个脾气暴躁的人，但他显然有一种不可思议的能力，能够说服那些他需要支持他的人。你知道，除了我们所描述的一切之外，他身上确实有一种个人魅力。
I swear I do not know nor can I think why, save what God our Lord wants me to do for your highnesses. I did only what Abraham did for Isaac and Moses for the people of Israel in Egypt. So it's amazing then, is it not? He's been sent back in chains and he's writing, comparing himself to Abraham and Moses, that there's a fourth voyage. How does he persuade Ferdinand and Isabella to back him for a fourth voyage? Because we've been talking about how he's a difficult man, he's a prickly man, but he clearly has an incredible ability to persuade people who he needs to persuade to back him. You know, there is a sense of charisma there as well as everything else we've been
当他抛出这些言论时，他们可能并没有像我们那样产生相同的反应，汤姆。所以我们听着他说这些把自己比作摩西的话，我们会说哥伦布显然是疯了。他在海上待得太久了。他瞎了。他经历了这一切。我认为极其虔诚的伊莎贝拉，在听到他这样描述自己时，可能相当受触动。再加上他们知道他擅长发现新事物——我的意思是，他发现了委内瑞拉——我要声明一下，所谓“发现”并不是说那里原本没有人，当然是有的，他也遇到过他们，但他确实是第一个发现那里的欧洲人。所以他们认为，而且也是因为他们一直在与葡萄牙人竞争，所以瓦斯科·达·加马
describing. When he's coming out with this, they perhaps don't have the same reaction that we do, Tom. So we listen to him say, comparing himself with Moses. And we say Columbus is clearly losing his marbles. He's been at sea too long. He's blind. He's all this stuff. I think Isabella, who is incredibly pious, is perhaps quite moved when she hears him describing himself in this way. Plus, they know he is good at discovering things i mean he discovered venezuela i'm going to say discovered i mean it's not like there weren't people there already of course there were and he had met them but he's the first european to discover it so they think they're also because they're in competition with the portuguese all this time so vasco de
刚刚回来——我们在去年关于葡萄牙人的节目中谈到过瓦斯科·达·加马，瓦斯科·达·加马在1499年回国了。而事实上——这就是哥伦布令人惊奇的地方，哥伦布简直是个十足的失败者。他完全没有找到中国，也没有找到印度。曾经拒绝过他的葡萄牙人从一开始就是对的，他们的人成功了，已经回国了。这实际上让哥伦布和西班牙人感到非常尴尬，因为葡萄牙人基本上是在对他们说：“你们过去七年一直在喋喋不休，而我们现在实际上已经找到了。”
gama has just got back we talked about vasco de gama in our portuguese episodes last year vasco de gama got back in 1499 and he actually i mean this is the thing with columbus the amazing thing columbus is just a complete failure he has completely failed to find china he's failed to find india the portuguese who had turned him down were right all along their guy has done it has got back which is actually very embarrassing for Columbus and for the Spanish because the Portuguese are basically saying to them, you know, you've been wittering on for the last seven years about, we've actually now found it.
我们是对的。也许正是因为这种竞争，西班牙当局认为他不擅长行政管理，但他擅长发现新事物。我的意思是，他写信给教皇亚历山大六世（Alexander Borgia）。他说：“我找到了伊甸园，”这绝对是个好消息。但同时，他不是还提议发起一场
We were right. Perhaps because of that competition, the Spanish authorities think he's not good at administering, but he's good at finding things. I mean, he writes to the Pope, Alexander Borgia. He says, I found the Garden of Eden, which is great news. But also, isn't he proposing to launch, to attack Mecca
向西航行去进攻麦加的行动吗？是的，他有各种各样的宏伟计划。我们在第一集中讨论过的那些十字军东征式的狂热。这绝对依然存在。我的意思是，仅仅因为他们征服了格拉纳达，并且已经安顿下来
by sailing westwards? Yeah, he's got all this stuff. All these schemes. That crusading stuff that we talked about in episode one. It's absolutely still there. I mean, just because they've conquered Granada and they've sort of settled down
赚了一些钱，并不意味着斐迪南已经放弃了成为最后一个世界皇帝、夺取耶路撒冷、消灭伊斯兰教、成为那个将世界统一在基督旗帜下的君主的野心。而哥伦布则在某种程度上对他说：“我能做到这一点。”而且，他的热那亚关系网仍在为他提供资金。因此，他获得了教皇的批准得以出行。热那亚银行表示他们将再次支持他。于是，在1502年5月，哥伦布踏上了第四次航行的征程。这一次，是一次规模小得多的远征。他只有四艘卡拉维尔帆船。相比之下第二次航行时有17艘。所以他的规模基本上回到了第一次航行的水平。
and they're making a bit of money, it doesn't mean that Ferdinand has given up his ambition to be the last world emperor, to take Jerusalem, to wipe out Islam, to be that monarch who unites the world behind the banners of Christ. And Columbus is sort of saying to him, you know, I can do that. He's also, his Genoese network is still giving him funds. So he gets permission from the Pope to go. The Bank of Genoa says, say they'll back him again. And so it is that in May 1502, Columbus heads off for voyage number four. This time, it's a much smaller voyage. He's only got four caravels. So 17 with voyage number two. So he's sort of back down to virtually the level that he was with voyage number one.
不同的是，这一次他实际上被禁止访问伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。所以当他到达伊斯帕尼奥拉岛时，那里有一位新总督名叫尼古拉·德·奥万多（Nicolás de Obando），奥万多对他说：“这里不欢迎你。你知道的，法律规定你现在不准上岸。”而哥伦布则说：“嗯，有一场巨大的风暴要来了。你知道的，请让我上岸吧。”
The difference is that this time he's actually banned from visiting Hispaniola. So he gets to Hispaniola. They've got a new governor there called Nicolás de Obando. And Obando says to him, you're not welcome. You know, you're not allowed to land. It's against the law now. And Columbus says, well, there's a massive storm coming. You know, please let me land. And Columbus says, well, there's a massive storm coming.
而奥万多认为哥伦布在撒谎，部分原因是他正准备向西班牙派遣一支珍宝船队，他认为哥伦布是想阻止他。实际上，哥伦布并没有撒谎。那支珍宝船队几乎全军覆没。哥伦布在一个海湾避难。他的船队遭受了惨重的破坏。
You know, please let me land. And Obando thinks that Columbus is lying, partly because he's about to send a treasure fleet back to Spain. And he thinks Columbus wants to stop him. Actually, Columbus wasn't lying. The treasure fleet is almost all destroyed. Columbus shelters in a bay. His fleet is very battered.
这就是博巴蒂利亚被淹死的风暴吗？是的。所以博巴蒂利亚淹死了，还有罗尔丹，也就是那个之前与哥伦布闹翻的家伙。所以从某种程度上说，哥伦布成了笑到最后的人。
And is this the storm in which Bobadilla gets drowned? Yeah. So Bobadilla is drowned and also Roldan, the guy who Columbus had fallen out with before. So Columbus is sort of the last man standing to some extent.
我的意思是，他懂大海。他是一位非常、非常出色的航海家。所以他们的船被大风吹到了伯利兹。然后他又进行了一次如此不可思议的航行，以至于如果他仅仅完成了这一件事，就足以撑起一期播客了。是的，他绝对能在《历史的余烬》里占有一席之地。
I mean, he knows the sea. He's a very, very good mariner. So they're blown off to Belize. And he then does another of these incredible voyages that actually, if he'd just done this, it would be enough for a podcast. Yeah, he'd earn a place on the rest of his history.
所以他沿着中美洲海岸向下航行。他遇到了可能是来自墨西哥尤卡坦地区的玛雅人。他喝了普尔克酒（pulque），对吧？他喝了普尔克酒，那是他们的一种啤酒，我猜是吧。他把它比作英国啤酒。哦，没有比这更高的赞誉了，汤姆。不。太棒了。
So he sails down the coast of Central, along the coast of Central America. He meets people that are probably Maya from Yucatan, Mexico. He drinks pulque, doesn't he? He drinks pulque, their sort of beer, I guess it is. He compares it to English beer. Oh, there's no higher praise, Tom. No. Wonderful.
真有他的。他本该知道这些的，因为当然啦，他曾经去过布里斯托尔，对吧？是的，还有爱尔兰，曾在那里晃荡过。所以他会……在克利夫顿（Clifton）闲逛。完全正确，完全正确。
Good for him. He would have known that because, of course, he'd been to Bristol, hadn't he? Yeah. And Ireland and sort of hanging around there. So he would have... Hanging out in Clifton. Exactly. Exactly.
而且玛雅人显然要精明得多。他们拥有用木头制作的非常精美的宝剑，还穿着染色的棉质衣服。他想：“这显然意味着我身处东南亚，我离恒河太近了。”是的，他觉得自己离转角只有10天路程了。是的，这太有趣了，因为这是这样一个时刻：所有人，绝对是所有人，都认为这是一个新世界——我的意思是，这现在已经成了一种陈词滥调，再过几年这里就要以亚美利哥·韦斯普奇（Amerigo Vespucci）的名字重新命名了，这未免太残酷了吧，不是吗？确实很残酷。嗯，韦斯普奇本人其实也是一位相当了不起的探险家，
And the Meyer are clearly more sophisticated. They have very fancy swords out of wood and they have dyed cotton clothes he thinks well this clearly means I'm in Southeast Asia I'm so near the river Ganges yes he thinks he's only 10 days from the corner yeah and this is so interesting because it's a point to which everybody else absolutely everybody else thinks this is the new world i mean that's now become a cliche we're only a few years away from it being renamed after amerigo vespucci which is harsh isn't it it is harsh well vespucci himself is actually quite an impressive explorer
但这也是事实，我猜这确实很残酷，但部分原因也是哥伦布自己咎由自取，因为他只是拒绝承认这个新大陆的存在。他一直说：“你怎么能用一个甚至根本不相信它存在的人来命名它呢？”所以他一路南下到达巴拿马，然后在那个地方宣称自己身处马来西亚的马六甲海峡。人们对他说：“这里有一个地峡，如果你穿过去，就会看到另一片海洋。”而他却说：“哦，这绝对是马来西亚，我知道自己究竟在哪里。”因此他仍然在试图把一切都塞进他那荒谬的理论中。但这里其实是巴拿马。这确实是巴拿马。所以我的意思是，他居然没有死，这简直是个奇迹，因为正如我所说的那样，
but it is yes i suppose it is harsh but it's partly columbus's own fault because he just refuses to accept that it even exists he keeps saying how can you name it after somebody who doesn't even yeah believe it so he goes all the way down to panama and he says at that point he says he's in malaysia the strait of malacca people say to him there's an isthmus and if you go across it there will be another ocean and he says oh well this is definitely malaysia you know i know exactly where I am. And so he's still trying to fit everything into his sort of mad theories. But it's Panama. It is Panama. So I mean, it's amazing he doesn't die, actually, because as I said,
许多造访巴拿马这样热带地区的人，最后都落得个极其悲惨的下场。但哥伦布没有。他们的船只已经彻底损毁，船身爬满了白 termites（白蚁）。其中一位历史学家说，哥伦布在这个阶段经常长时间待在瞭望台里跟上帝对话，我认为这对于你的船长来说大概不是什么理想的状态。他有一个习惯，不是吗？每当他感到极度沮丧时，他就会乘船驶向海洋深处去与上帝交流。是的。我的意思是，这很容易让我们……是的，这是一种方济各会式的隐修。确实如此，但这对他很管用。他完成了四次惊人的航行，并且活着归来讲述这些故事。而我们俩，汤姆，都没有做过……
a lot of people who visit tropical places like Panama, they come to very sticky ends. But Columbus doesn't. They're absolutely shattered. Their ships are riddled with termites. One of the historians says Columbus by this stage was spending long periods in the crow's nest talking to God, which I think is probably not ideal for the captain of your ship. He had a policy, didn't he, of whenever he was too depressed that he'd go out in a ship out into the ocean depths and commune with God. Yeah. I mean, I suppose it's easy for us to... Yeah, it's a kind of Franciscan retreat. It is, but also it worked for him. He did four amazing voyages and returns to tell the tale. And neither of us, Tom, has done...
我们俩谁也没做过，是的。甚至连一次都没有。所以，向哥伦布致敬。然后，实际上，哥伦布故事中最疯狂的元素之一来了：当他们扬帆返回伊斯帕尼奥拉岛时，被一场巨大的风暴吹离了航线，最终被困在了牙买加的北海岸。基本上，他们的船只情况太糟糕了，以至于他们不得不把船拆了，
Neither of us have done that, no. So much as one. So good for Columbus. And then actually one of the craziest elements of all the Columbus story, they are blown by a massive storm as they're sailing back to Hispaniola and end up being marooned on the north coast of Jamaica. And they basically, the ships are in such a terrible condition, they have to turn them into
在海滩上搭建成某种避难所。他们分配了口粮，然后说：“好吧，我们现在该怎么办？”哥伦布手下的两个人，一个叫迭戈·门德斯（Diego Mendez），另一个叫巴托洛梅奥·菲耶斯基（Bartolomeo Fieschi，是个热那亚人），他们说：“好吧，我们划独木舟去搬救兵。”他们也确实这么做了。这太惊人了，不是吗？他们横渡了120英里的海洋。他们带了大约六名泰诺人（Tainos），天气酷热难耐，他们极其口渴，其中一名当地人因极度干渴而死。他们在大海中央发现了一块礁石，得以收集一些雨水并吃了一些软体动物。然而，即便在他们到达伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的西部之后，他们还必须步行另外300英里才能找到救援。
sort of shelters on the beach. They divide up the rations and they say, well, what are we going to do? And two of Columbus's men, a guy called Diego Mendez and Bartolomeo Fieschi, who's Genoese, they say, well, we'll go by canoe to go and get help. And they do. That's amazing, isn't it? They cover 120 miles of sea. They have, I think, about six tainos with them intense heat they're incredibly thirsty one of the natives dies of thirst uh they find a rock in the middle of the the ocean where they are able to get some rainwater and eat some mollusks and then but even after they've got to hispaniola they're the western bit and they've got to Hispaniola, the western bit, and they've got to then go another 300 miles over land to go and get help.
不可思议的是，当他们终于找到伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的总督并说：“哥伦布在牙买加遭遇海难了，请派救援吧。”总督却回答：“不。”他说：“我恨哥伦布。他们叫他法老。法老。别理那个法老。”
And the incredible thing is when they finally get to the governor of Hispaniola and say, Columbus is shipwrecked on Jamaica. Please send help. He says, no. He says, I hate Columbus. They call him the pharaoh. The pharaoh. Leave the pharaoh alone.
是的。法老是个可怕的人。我不会派人去救他的。所以接下来是一场漫长的拖延，哥伦布在牙买加苦苦等待救援。毫无疑问，哥伦布的船员中爆发了一场叛变。我的意思是，这对他管理风格是一个极其辛辣的讽刺：即使当他们的船在海滩上撞毁、只能栖身于破碎的船残骸中时，他们依然彼此内讧。其中两人领导了一场叛变。他们带着一些超载的船只、一些装载了泰诺人的临时船只，沿着牙买加海岸扬帆驶去。
Yeah. The pharaoh is a terrible man. I'm not sending help for him. So then there's a long delay while Columbus is waiting for help. Unsurprisingly, there's a rebellion that breaks out among Columbus's crew. I mean, it's an extraordinary indictment of his managerial style that even when their shipwreck's living in the sort of the shattered wreck of their ship on the beach, they still all fall out with each other. Two of them lead a rebellion. They sail off along the coast of Jamaica with some overloaded boats, some makeshift boats with some Tainos.
由于严重超载，他们竟然把所有的泰诺人都扔进了海里，我想我们俩都会同意这绝对是极其恶劣的行为。是的。然后他们不得不沿着陆地跋涉返回，一路杀戮、抢劫并强奸。接着他们又灰溜溜地跑回哥伦布的营地，说道：“好吧，我们确实叛变了，但结果并不顺利。所以让我们和好吧。”是的，让我们和好吧。
They're massively, because they're overloaded, they throw all the Tainos overboard, which I think we can both agree is very bad behavior. Yeah. They then have to make their way back on land, killing and robbing and sort of raping as they go. Then they pitch up back at Columbus's camp and say, well, we did rebel, but that didn't work out. So let's make up. Yeah, let's make up.
于是他们就在那里呆着。哥伦布近乎发疯，喋喋不休地念叨着所罗门、伊甸园和恒河。最后，在1504年6月，尼古拉·德·奥万多说：“好吧，行吧，我会派救援的。”于是他们派出了救援。哥伦布获救了，并基本上被遣送回了西班牙。
So they're there. Columbus is sort of half mad. He's just wittering on about Solomon and the Garden of Eden and the River Ganges. And finally, in June 1504, Nicolaus de Obando says, fine, all right, you know, I'll send help. And they send help. Columbus is rescued and basically sent back to Spain.
当他回到西班牙时——那是1504年11月——他听到了一个坏消息。伊莎贝拉女王已经病危了。而她一直是他的特许庇护人。是的，她在1504年11月26日去世了，她就是阿拉贡的凯瑟琳（Catherine of Aragon）的母亲。而当她去世时，对哥伦布来说基本上就意味着一切都结束了，大幕落下了。
And when he gets back to Spain, so that's November 1504, he has a bit of bad news. Queen Isabella is on her deathbed. And she's his particular patron. Yeah, she dies on the 26th of November 1504, the mother of Catherine of Aragon. And when she dies, that's kind of it, curtains for him, really.
我的意思是，我想到了那个时候他已经病得很重，而且双目近盲，他的理智已经被关于伊甸园、梨子、海难、风暴以及所有人都叫他法老的种种事情折腾得混乱不堪。这可对你的健康没什么好处，不是吗？在听了那四次航行的故事之后，汤姆，你还会跟哥伦布签约参加第五次航行吗？
I mean, I think by that point he's pretty ill, and he's half blind and his wits are so scrambled by all this stuff about the Garden of Eden, pears, shipwrecks, storms, everybody calling him the pharaoh. I wouldn't do wonders for your health, would you? After hearing the stories of those four voyages, Tom, would you sign up for voyage number five with Columbus?
不，我不会。不，我也不会。我毫不畏惧地这么说。好吧，你也不会有机会的，因为他基本上只是四处游荡，拖着病体跟在斐迪南国王身后，含混不清地试图争取新航行的批准，但同时他又极度痴迷于自己的头衔，无休止地试图为自己获得头衔的确认。然后在1506年5月……
No, I wouldn't. No, nor would I. Not afraid to say it. Well, you wouldn't get the chance because he sort of just drifts around, trudging around after King Ferdinand, vaguely trying to get permission for new voyages, but also he's so obsessed with his titles, just try endlessly to get confirmation of his own titles. And then in May 1506...
而他确实拿到了，不是吗？是的，他拿到了。他确实拿到了。所以他总是抱怨斐迪南辜负了他。但实际上斐迪南人相当不错。你知道，国王和女王，我不认为他们对待他不好。我认为在他们批准他进行第一次航行之前，他们就已经给他发了养老金。甚至在经历了这种荒诞不经的行为之后，
Which he gets, doesn't he? Yeah, he does. He does. He absolutely does. So he's always complaining that Ferdinand is letting him down. But actually Ferdinand's quite good. You know, the King and Queen, I don't think they treated him badly. I think they paid him a pension before they even gave him the permission to go on voyage number one. And even after this sort of shambolic behavior,
他们也从未与他决裂。嗯，斐迪南安排了哥伦布的儿子迭戈迎娶阿尔巴公爵（Duke of Alba）的侄女。所以实际上，哥伦布得到了他想要的一切，因为哥伦布这个出身卑微的织工之子，最终成了一脉公爵家族的始祖。这绝对是正确的，他的那个头衔——也就是“大洋海海军上将”——我想这个头衔至今仍由他的后代继承。所以，确实有这样一个人，不是吗？所以他在1506年5月20日于巴利亚多利德（Valladolid）去世。他的头顶显然笼罩着一团阴云，带着一种未能板上钉钉地证实自己确实抵达了亚洲的遗憾。是的，但他死时一定觉得自己取得了伟大的成就。
they never break with him. Well, Ferdinand fixes for Diego, Columbus's son, to marry the niece of the Duke of Alba. So actually,us gets everything he wants because columbus this son of a weaver who's risen from nothing ends up the progenitor of a line of dukes i mean that's absolutely right the um the title that he has which is um admiral of the ocean sea uh i think that's inherited to this day by his descendants so i think there's a man who is so there is that isn't that so he dies on um 20th of may 1506 in valladolid there's obviously a kind of cloud hanging over him a feeling of regret that he hasn't nailed down the fact that he's reached asia yeah but he must have been able to die feeling that he had achieved great things
如果能知道他对自己取得了伟大成就这一点哪一个感到更高兴，那将是一件非常有趣的事。而且，知道他究竟对哪件事更满意会很有意思：是他曾完成所有这些非凡的远征这一事实，还是他在死后证明了自己是一脉公爵家族始祖这一事实？这是一个好问题。是的，因为这一切总是关乎……对他来说，很大程度上都是关于地位的。是的，太多的地位追求了。
and it would be interesting to know what he was more pleased to die feeling that he had achieved great things. And it would be interesting to know what he was more pleased about. The fact that he had made all these extraordinary crossings or the fact that after his death, he would prove to be the progenitor of a line of dukes. That's a good question. Yeah, because it was always about. I suspect the latter. So much of it was about status for him. Yeah, so much of it.
所以为他的儿子争取地位，为他的儿子确认那些头衔。无论如何，我们现在是不是该休息一下了？当我们回来时，让我们来看看……嗯，关于他的遗体后来发生了什么的非凡故事。哦，是的。以及
So getting his son, getting those titles confirmed for his son. Anyway, should we take a break now? And when we come back, let's look at the, well, the extraordinary story of what happens to his body. Oh, yes. And the way in which
他在几个世纪里、特别是近年来在关于他的历史遗产的辩论中是如何被世人所铭记的。所以我们休息回来后就会聊这些。几分钟后见。
he has been remembered over the course of the centuries and particularly in more recent years in the debate over his legacy. So we'll do that when we come back. We'll see you in a few minutes.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。儿童版的克里斯托弗·哥伦布传记充当了种族主义和帝国主义的入门读物。这些书教导年轻人接受白人统治有色人种的权力，接受强大国家统治弱小国家的权力。这是威廉·比格洛（William Bigelow），他是一名美国高中教师，也是《反思哥伦布》（Rethinking Columbus）的作者。多米尼克，跟我们本期节目开头的诗歌相比，这确实是一种反思。这确实是一种反思，是的。那首诗，我想大概写于20世纪70年代。这让你对过去几十年中发生的舆论革命有了一些深刻的感受。确实如此，因为我认为比格洛先生的那段话，实际上大约出自20世纪90年代左右。哦，是吗？哦，原来如此。好吧，那么这可能是在1992年周年纪念的背景下……正是如此。在我们讨论这个之前，让我们先来看看他死后紧接着发生的余波……我们谈到了斐迪南如何照顾迭戈，以及是的，哥伦布家族的遗产。事实上，迭戈最终成为了印度群岛的总督，不是吗？
I'm Marina Hyde. And I richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Children's Biographies of Christopher Columbus function as primers on racism and imperialism. These books teach youngsters to accept the right of white people to rule over people of color, of powerful nations to dominate weaker nations. That is William Bigelow, who is a US high school teacher and the author of Rethinking Columbus. And Dominic, compared to the poem with which we opened this episode, that is indeed a rethinking. That is a rethinking, yeah. The poem, I think, was written in the 70s. And that gives you some sense of the revolution in opinion
他确实当上了。他去了圣多明各。我想他一直在那里待到16世纪20年代初。所以在墨西哥被征服期间他一直都在那里。我的意思是，他是个大人物。而且西班牙王室确实履行了对哥伦布的承诺。当他在那里时，哥伦布其实——他死于巴利亚多利德。他被安葬在那里的方济各会修道院里。
that has happened over the past few decades. It is, because I think that quote from Mr. Bigelow, I think that's actually from the 1990s or so. Oh, is it? Oh, right. Okay, so that would be in the context, perhaps, um the the anniversary in 1992 exactly before we come to that let's just look at the immediate aftermath of what happens uh in in the wake of his death so we we talked about how ferdinand looks after diego and yes columbus's kind of legacy the legacy of his family and actually i mean diego ends up the governor of the Indies, doesn't he?
在过去几十年里发生的。是的，因为我认为比格洛先生的那句话，我想那实际上是20世纪90年代左右的。哦，是吗？哦，对的。好的，所以那可能是在1992年那个周年纪念的背景下，正好在我们讲到那个之前，让我们先看看他死后紧接着发生的那些事，所以我们讨论了费尔南多是如何照顾迭戈的，是的，还有哥伦布的某种遗产，他家族的遗产，实际上，我的意思是迭戈最终成为了西印度群岛的总督，对吧？
He does. He kind of, he goes out to Santo Domingo. And he's there until the early 1520s, I think. So he's there while Mexico is being conquered. I mean, he's a big man. And the Spanish crown absolutely do honour those promises to Columbus. And while he's out there, Columbus has been, he died in Valladolid. He gets buried there in the Franciscan monastery.
是的。他去了圣多明各。我想他一直在那里待到1520年代初。所以当墨西哥被征服时他在那里。我的意思是，他是个大人物。西班牙王室确实履行了对哥伦布的那些承诺。当他在那里的时候，哥伦布一直……他死于巴利亚多利德。他被埋葬在那里的方济各会修道院里。
Then he gets moved to Seville, his body. And then because Diego is out in Hispaniola, he has him brought out to Santo Domingo and buried there, where he stays for as long as Hispaniola remains Spanish. But when Santo Domingo becomes French, which it does at the end of the 18th century, Columbus's body is moved to Havana in Cuba. And then the Cubans rebel against the Spanish and become independent. And so Columbus's body is taken back to Seville, where it's buried in a rather kind of overblown monument. Yeah, ginormous monuments in the cathedral. And is there to this day and so there is there is um there is skepticism as to whether these the body that is said to be columbus's after all this transfer is
然后他的遗体被运到了塞维利亚。后来，由于迭戈在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，他让人把遗体运到圣多明各并埋葬在那里，只要伊斯帕尼奥拉岛还是西班牙领土，他就一直留在那。但当圣多明各变成法国领土时——也就是在18世纪末，哥伦布的遗体被移到了古巴的哈瓦那。然后古巴人反抗西班牙并赢得了独立。于是哥伦布的遗体又被运回了塞维利亚，被埋葬在一个相当夸张的纪念碑里。是的，大教堂里巨大的纪念碑。而且至今还在那儿，所以，关于这个被认为是哥伦布的遗体在经历这一切转移后，
actually columbus's that's right because i think it's still there are still competing claims aren't there between the dominican republic and spain and whether in fact the columbus's body might have been dismembered and different bits of him are perhaps in different places. There has been talk of DNA testing, though it all seems completely fruitless to me. I think everybody should claim, you know, a little bit of Columbus. But if you want a metaphor, this idea of Columbus's posthumous remains kind of endlessly being moved from place to place and being torn to pieces by competing interests is a very good metaphor, isn't it? It is. Although the funny thing is that Columbus at first, so in the 16th century, partly because I suppose he wasn't Spanish, the Spanish don't make a huge
实际上是不是哥伦布的，一直存在着怀疑。没错，因为我觉得现在多米尼加共和国和西班牙之间仍然存在着争端，而且哥伦布的遗体是否可能曾被肢解，他的不同部分或许散落在不同的地方。人们曾讨论过进行DNA检测，尽管对我来说这似乎完全是徒劳的。我觉得每个人都可以认领哪怕一小部分哥伦布。但如果你想要一个隐喻，哥伦布死后遗骸被无休止地从一个地方运到另一个地方，并在各方利益的争夺中被撕成碎片，这真的是一个很好的隐喻，不是吗？确实是。尽管有趣的是，哥伦布一开始，也就是在16世纪，部分原因我想是因为他不是西班牙人，西班牙人并没有把哥伦布当回事。
deal of Columbus. In fact, lots of people obviously are still alive who hated Columbus. They thought of him as the pharaoh. So Columbus is not really fated as a great hero. You know, there aren't cities named after him. But he does. I mean, he is established as the discovery. He's the discoverer, but the New World is not named after him. It's named after Vespucci, who sailed along the coast of Brazil. The two figures who sort of dominate the sort of Spanish accounts of the sort of conquest of the New World are Cortes and Pizarro. So they're the conquerors of the Aztecs and the Incas, because they really do bring back gold,
事实上，显然当时还有很多人活着，他们是恨哥伦布的。他们把他视为法老。所以哥伦布并没有被真正奉为什么伟大的英雄。你知道的，没有以他名字命名的城市。但他确实……我的意思是，他被确立为发现者，他是发现者，但新世界并不是以他的名字命名的。而是以韦斯普奇的名字命名的，他曾沿着巴西海岸航行。在西班牙关于征服新世界的记载中，占据主导地位的两个核心人物是科尔特斯和皮萨罗。他们是阿兹特克人和印加人的征服者，因为他们确实带回了黄金，
because they do bring back gold. And also because they're, you know, there's something more obviously sort of, I mean, as violent as they were, there's something more obviously sort of i mean as as as as violent as they were there's something more obviously swashbuckling about those stories about them fighting their way in and out of capital cities and things that seem to fit with the sort of marshall's mindset of the spanish empire better than this sort of very disputatious genoese marinos wrong going on about breasts. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Exactly.
因为他们确实带回了黄金。而且还因为，你知道的，他们身上有一种更明显的……我的意思是，尽管他们同样残暴，但关于他们浴血奋战、杀入杀出各大城市的那些故事，明显更带有一种浪漫冒险色彩，这似乎比那个只会喋喋不休、满嘴乳房的满腹争论的热那亚水手，更能契合西班牙帝国尚武的心态。是的，完全正确。没错，完全正确。
And actually, the interesting thing with Columbus, I think, is that a lot of the debate about Columbus here or villain comes from the United States, which is actually, of course, a part of the world that Columbus never visited. Although he might have done, had he stayed on his course on the first voyage, he might have crashed into Florida.
事实上，关于哥伦布，我认为有趣的一点是，这里关于他是英雄还是恶棍的大量争论都源自美国，而实际上，这个地区当然是哥伦布从未涉足过的。尽管他本来可能会去，如果他在第一次航行时没有改变航向的话，他本可能会撞上佛罗里达。
But he didn't. So he never went to the United States. He didn didn't discover it he didn't colonize it but what was once the ormadaire i say the sacralization of of columbus the mythologization of columbus started in america in the 19th 18th 19th centuries so obviously if you think about the use of columbia the of Columbia, Columbus, Ohio. Columbia University. Columbia University. You get a bit of that in Latin America, obviously.
但他没有。所以他从未去过美国。他没有发现它，也没有对其进行殖民。但是，曾经的……我该怎么说呢，对哥伦布的神圣化、神话化始于19世纪、18世纪到19世纪的美国。所以显然，如果你想想哥伦比亚（Columbia）这个词的使用，哥伦布，俄亥俄州的哥伦布市。哥伦比亚大学。哥伦比亚大学。你在拉丁美洲显然也能看到一些这种影响。
The country, Columbia, Gran Colombia, which was Simon Bolivar's dream of a kind of United States of Latin America. But that's obviously the period, in particular, the North America of Manifest Destiny. And Columbus is seen as the progenitor of Manifest Destiny. Go West, young man man all of that stuff so martin van buren u.s president in the 1830s um commissioned a discovery of america's statue with columbus and a kind of cringing indian maiden which stood outside as well she might have cringed yeah well exactly Well, exactly. You're quite right, Tom. It stood outside the Capitol until it was removed in the mid of the 20th century. And why was it moved?
这个国家，哥伦比亚，大哥伦比亚共和国，那是西蒙·玻利瓦尔建立某种拉丁美洲合众国的梦想。但那显然是那个时期的产物，特别是北美“昭昭天命”的时期。哥伦布被视为“昭昭天命”的始作俑者。年轻人，去西部吧，诸如此类。所以19世纪30年代的美国总统马丁·范布伦，委托创作了一座发现美洲的雕像，上面有哥伦布和一个畏缩的印第安少女，这座雕像就立在——她确实可能会畏缩，是的，完全正确。完全正确，汤姆，你说得对。它一直立在国会大厦外面，直到20世纪中期才被移除。为什么要移除它呢？
Because it was felt to be, even then, to be... I think because even then, yeah, in the mid 20th century, it was just incredibly insensitive. Yeah. The image of Columbus is this sort of square-jawed, blue-eyed, European, this sort of model of heroic European exploration. That comes late 19th century, and it's largely a product of immigration to the US. And there are things like, there's a group called the Knights of Columbus, who were set up from the 1880s onwards. And they're Catholic Italian immigrants, largely, who need an American hero. so we began
因为即使在当时，人们也觉得它……我想是因为即使在20世纪中期，它也确实极其麻木不仁。是的。哥伦布的形象被塑造成那种方下巴、蓝眼睛的欧洲人，这种英雄式欧洲探险的典范。这产生于19世纪末，很大程度上是美国移民潮的产物。并且出现了一些组织，比如有一个叫哥伦布骑士会的团体，成立于18世纪80年代以后。他们大体上是天主教意大利裔移民，需要一个美国英雄。所以我们从
with the Sopranos episode yeah they're the Sopranos written by uh Mike Imperioli who plays Christopher yeah in the Sopranos and in that the whole I mean the whole plot of the episode revolves around the idea that these members of the of the mafia in New Jersey are obsessed with a sense of Italian-American pride and that Columbus is the focus for this. Yeah, that's exactly right. I think, and actually, that episode is hated by lots of Sopranos fans. I mean, the woker of the Sopranos fan, the more they dislike that episode, I think it's fair to say. But those groups, Italian-American groups, were lobbying because what they wanted was a founding father who was like them who was catholic and italian and involved in all kinds of bad
《黑道家族》的那集开始聊起。是的，那是迈克尔·因佩里奥利编剧的，他在《黑道家族》中饰演克里斯托弗。在那一集中，整集的剧情围绕着这样一个核心：新泽西州的这些黑手党成员痴迷于一种意裔美国人的自豪感，而哥伦布就是这种情感的寄托。是的，完全正确。我想，而且事实上，那一集遭到了许多《黑道家族》粉丝的讨厌。我的意思是，《黑道家族》的粉丝越是“觉醒”，他们就越不喜欢那一集，我觉得这样说挺公平的。但那些群体，即意裔美国人团体，一直在进行游说，因为他们想要的是一个像他们一样、信仰天主教且身为意大利人、并卷入了各种糟糕
behavior under bad behavior i mean that's that's i mean that is the that's the irony that's being played on in the sopranos episode isn't it i suppose it is that the mafia are not good for the reputation of italian americans and the sopranos isn't good for the reputation of Italian Americans and The Sopranos isn't good for the reputation of Italian Americans. So there's a lot of, you know, a slight hall of mirrors there. There is, yes. But they sort of, so what they do is they reinvent Columbus as this heroic square-jawed, heroic individualist
行为的开国元勋。说到糟糕的行为，我的意思是，这就是《黑道家族》那一集里玩味的反讽，不是吗？我想是的，黑手党对意裔美国人的名声不好，而《黑道家族》对意裔美国人的名声也不好，对意裔美国人的名声同样不好。所以这里面有很多……你知道的，有点像哈哈镜一样的效果。确实是的。但他们某种程度上……所以他们做的事，是将哥伦布重新塑造为这样一个英勇的、方下巴的、崇尚个人主义的英雄，
who is the sort of herald of manifest destiny. And in other words, it gives them... And of science, but a forward-thinking modern figure who gives them a hero that will rank alongside Washington, Jefferson, and Co., who are obviously all Protestants and Anglo-Saxon Protestants. And so they are pushing for a national holiday, so Columbus Day, from the 1880s or so.
他某种程度上是“昭昭天命”的先驱。换句话说，这赋予了他们……而且他还代表科学，是一个具有前瞻性的现代人物，这赋予了他们一个可以与华盛顿、杰斐逊等人平起平坐的英雄，而这些人显然都是新教徒和盎格鲁-萨克逊新教徒。因此，他们从18世纪80年代左右开始力推一个全国性的节日，也就是哥伦布日。
So it's actually – it wasn't made a federal holiday until 1971. Lyndon Johnson had passed the legislation or signed it off a couple of years earlier. And that's a point at which there's a kind of ethnicization of America. Anyway, you know, Italian-Americans, it's the era of the godfather, of the deer hunter, of all these kinds of things. But also Marlon Brando turning down his Oscar.
所以实际上——直到1971年它才成为联邦假日。林登·约翰逊在几年前通过了这项立法或签署了法令。那正是一个美国经历某种族群化（ethnicization）的时期。无论如何，你知道的，意裔美国人，那是《教父》、《猎鹿人》以及所有这类事物的时代。但这也是马龙·白兰度拒绝接受奥斯卡奖的时代。
Oh, yes. Yeah. and a native american turning up who i now gather isn't a native american that's right sachin little feather yes that's the uh is the name um yeah and actually columbus day interestingly has never been universally accepted so there are quite a lot of states where they were always very ambivalent about it places like new New Mexico and so on. And right now, there are some cities, some states in the United States where they insist on, they do not mark Columbus Day, or they declare it to be Indigenous Peoples Day instead. And that's not just, it'd be very tempting for us to say, oh, woke Americans. But actually, that's mirrored across Latin America. So from about the 1910s, 1920s, and this will ring a bell for people who listen to our World Cup podcasts about places like Argentina or Uruguay or Mexico.
哦，是的。是的，还有一个印第安人出场了，我现在了解到那其实并不是一个印第安人，没错，小羽毛（Sachen Littlefeather），是的，这就是……呃，这个名字。是的，而且有趣的是，哥伦布日从来没有被普遍接受过。所以有很多州对它一直非常矛盾，比如新墨西哥州等等。而现在，美国的一些城市和州坚持不庆祝哥伦布日，或者将其宣布为原住民日。这不仅仅是……如果我们说“哦，觉醒的美国人嘛”，那就太容易了。但实际上，这种现象在整个拉丁美洲也有所反映。因此，从1910年代、1920年代左右开始——这对于听过我们关于阿根廷、乌拉圭或墨西哥等国世界杯播客的听众来说会很熟悉。
There was a trend to have a Dia de la Raza, the day of the race, on the the 12th of October on Columbus Day. But in a lot of countries, Argentina, Peru, Colombia, Costa Rica, old friends in Costa Rica, they have renamed it things like Diversity Day, Indigenous Peoples Day, Cultural Encounters Day, all of these kinds of things. So in other words, it's not just a North American phenomenon to tilt against Columbus. Lots of people in Latin America are doing it too. And this is something that we've been talking about before, that the tradition of seeing what Columbus is doing in the new world, the raping, the enslavement as crimes,
当时有一种趋势，就是在10月12日哥伦布日设立“种族日”（Dia de la Raza）。但在许多国家——阿根廷、秘鲁、哥伦比亚、哥斯达黎加（我们在哥斯达黎加的老朋友们），他们将其重新命名为“多元文化日”、“原住民日”、“文化相遇日”之类的内容。换句话说，反对哥伦布不仅是北美的现象。拉丁美洲的许多人也在这样做。这就是我们之前一直在谈论的内容：将哥伦布在新世界所做的事情——强奸、奴役视为罪行的这种传统，
is a tradition that is imported by the Spanish. We don't know what the Tainos thought. I mean, presumably they weren't in favour of it at all, but since they left no writings about it, we don't know what the Tainos thought. I mean, presumably they weren't in favour of it at all, but since they left no writings about it, we don't know what they thought. So that tradition of seeing what Columbus did is inherited from Spanish writers who were criticising him. And it has always been there. I mean, it's particularly strong in Protestant narratives for obvious reasons. It becomes conflated with Catholic oppression, but it's always been there. And in preparation for this, I listened to a very, very old episode
是西班牙人引入的一种传统。我们不知道泰诺人是怎么想的。我的意思是，据推测他们绝对不会赞成这种做法，但由于他们没有留下任何相关的文字记录，我们不知道泰诺人是怎么想的。我的意思是，据推测他们绝对不会赞成这种做法，但由于他们没有留下任何相关的文字记录，我们不知道他们是怎么想的。所以，看待哥伦布所作所为的那种传统，是继承自那些批评他的西班牙作家。而且这种传统一直存在。我的意思是，由于显而易见的原因，它在新教叙事中尤为强烈。它与天主教的压迫混为一谈，但它一直都在。为了做这期节目，我听了一集非常非常古老的节目，
of Letter from America by Alastair Cooke, who was a BBC British journalist who explained America to BBC listeners. And he was talking about the celebrations, so the 500th anniversary celebrations in 1992. So there was a huge world expo in Seville, specifically, you know, the burial place of supposedly of Columbus. And the theme of the expo was, I think, the age of exploration. So it couldn't have been more clearly identified with Columbus. But when the Spanish king, Juan Carlos, before he disgraced himself and had to abdicate, he gives a kind of speech of welcome and he never once mentions Christopher Columbus. Yeah.
那是阿拉斯泰尔·库克（Alastair Cooke）的《来自美国的信》。他是英国广播公司（BBC）的英国记者，负责向BBC听众解释美国。他当时在谈论庆祝活动，也就是1992年的500周年庆典。当时在塞维利亚举办了一个巨大的世界博览会，特别是因为那是据称埋葬哥伦布的地方。世博会的主题我想是大航海时代。所以它不可能与哥伦布有更明确的联系了。但当时任西班牙国王胡安·卡洛斯——在他名誉扫地不得不退位之前——发表欢迎致辞时，他竟然一次也没有提到克里斯托弗·哥伦布。是的。
And Alistair Cooke is kind of wondering about this and he relates it to the sense of embarrassment in America, in the United States, where there had been lots of plans being made to celebrate the anniversary, places with any kind of link to Columbus, you know, Columbia University, District of Columbia, all those kinds of places, and saying, well, actually, they've been overtaken by a deep sense of embarrassment. And he says, I don't know where this come from. He's describing it. And he says, words to the effect, what no one has been able to explain is why this has suddenly happened, the sense of embarrassment about Columbus. But actually, it's very clear why words to the effect what no one has been able to explain is why this has suddenly happened the
阿拉斯泰尔·库克对此感到有些困惑，他将其与美国那种尴尬感联系起来。在美国，当时曾有许多计划来庆祝这个周年纪念，那些与哥伦布有任何联系的地方，比如哥伦比亚大学、哥伦比亚特区等等所有这些地方，都在说，实际上，它们已经被一种深深的尴尬感所淹没。他说，我不知道这种情绪是从哪里来的。他在描述这种现象时说，大致意思是，没有人能够解释为什么会突然发生这种事，这种对哥伦布的尴尬感。但实际上，原因非常明显……大致意思是，没有人能够解释为什么会突然发生这种事，这种对哥伦布的尴尬感，但实际上，
sense of embarrassment about columbus but actually it's very clear why it's happened and where it's come from is it's a continuous tradition reaching back centuries and centuries well you mentioned uh las casas the priest who was active he was a kind of a conquistador himself he was active in cuba wasn't he in the early 1500s 1510s and then he witnessed his massacres and he kind of it's like the scales fall from his eyes and he becomes the great protector of the indians i think he was given that title wasn't he protector of the indians and he i mean you're saying it's taken up by protestants but it's actually catholic writers who first create this idea that the conquest of the new world, that Columbus, the voyages, all of that sort of business was rotten from the very beginning with rape and violence.
发生的原因以及它的根源非常清晰，这是一个延续了几个世纪的传统。嗯，你提到了……呃，拉斯卡萨斯，这位活跃的牧师，他自己其实也曾是个征服者，他在16世纪初（1510年代）活跃于古巴，当时他目睹了大屠杀，然后他那种感觉就像是眼前的迷雾突然散去，他成了印第安人的伟大保护者。我想他被授予过那个称号，对吧？“印第安人的保护者”。我的意思是，你刚才说这是被新教徒采纳的，但实际上是天主教作家首先创造了这种观点，即对新世界的征服、哥伦布的航行以及所有这类勾当，从一开始就充斥着强奸和暴力，从根子上就是腐烂的。
And some historians now would go along with what they say. Some would, some think Las Casas was exaggerating. One of the arguments that people have is about genocide. I personally do not think it makes any sense to accuse Columbus of genocide because it's absolutely not what he wanted. He wanted the locals. We've kind of made that clear from the beginning. You could argue that one of the repercussions and unanticipated consequences, I suppose you would say, of his arrival is genocide and that pretty much all the indigenous people of the Caribbean die. But disease plays a large part in that. And I think it's very
现在有些历史学家会赞同他们的说法。有些人会，有些人认为拉斯卡萨斯夸大其辞了。人们争论的焦点之一是关于种族灭绝。就我个人而言，我认为指控哥伦布犯有种族灭绝罪是毫无道理的，因为这绝不是他的本意。他是想要当地人的。我们从一开始就把这一点说得很清楚。你可以认为，他的到来所带来的反响和非预期后果——我想你会这么说——之一就是种族灭绝，加勒比地区几乎所有的原住民都消亡了。但疾病在其中扮演了很大一部分角色。而且我认为，
harsh to blame the Spanish. You would no more blame the Spanish for bringing smallpox than you would blame somebody for giving you COVID, I would say. But I think you could absolutely legitimately argue that their ability to withstand disease, that they're a broken people because their entire way of life has been destroyed and they're having to adjust to new ways of living, which are basically involves them having to work in mines. I think that's absolutely right, Tom. And I think that, you know, when your entire way of understanding the world has been shattered, and we talked about this in the episode we did on the aztecs as well that the impact of disease is greater when you feel kind of emotionally maybe spiritually broken yeah and again you know we don't know because as we say we you know we have no record it's it's
把这归咎于西班牙人未免太严苛了。你责怪西班牙人带来天花，就跟责怪某人传染给你新冠一样荒谬，我是这么认为的。但我认为你绝对可以合乎逻辑地争论说，他们抵御疾病的能力被削弱了，他们成了一个破碎的民族，因为他们整个的生活方式都被摧毁了，他们不得不去适应新的生活方式，而这基本上意味着他们必须在矿里劳作。汤姆，我认为你说得完全正确。而且我认为，当一个人理解世界的所有方式都支离破碎时——我们在做关于阿兹特克人的那一集节目中也谈到过这一点——当你感到情感上、或许精神上都已经崩溃时，疾病的影响就会更大。是的，而且再次强调，你知道的，我们并不知道，因为正如我们所说，我们没有任何记录，
it's hard to imagine how how utterly dislocating and devastating what happens to them in the space of what a few decades not even a few decades i mean 10 15 years maybe yeah start to finish las casas and other people actually write about exactly what you say they say when the smallpox comes when they're they're starving and so on they say it was horrible to watch you know people just sat there waiting to die or killed themselves they it's as though they as though their world had just been completely turned upside down and all their assumptions destroyed, their children taken away, families broken up, all of this business, and they just feel they have nothing to live for. And I think
很难想象在短短几十年甚至不到几十年的时间里——也就是10年、15年左右吧，从头到尾——发生在他们身上的事情是多么具有颠覆性和毁灭性。是的，拉斯卡萨斯和其他人确实写到了你所说的那种情况，他们说当天花来袭时，当他们忍饥挨饿的时候，他们说眼睁睁看着这一切简直太可怕了，你知道的，人们只是坐在那里等死或者自杀。这就好像他们的世界被彻底颠覆，所有的假设都被摧毁，孩子被夺走，家庭离散，所有这些事情让他们觉得生无可恋。我想
you can absolutely see that people would have thought like that, that the men with beards and swords have turned up and destroyed everything that they took for granted. And one of the reasons why this perspective on Columbus accelerates becomes more pronounced in the 70s, in the 80s, into the 90s, I think is partly because it's focused by the anniversary, but also the perspective that is offered by the civil rights movement in America, which has black Americans as its focus. But of course, it spills outwards because the idea that specifically white Europeans have done to portions of the world what followed in the wake of Columbus's discovery is it's there in the campaign against apartheid in South Africa. It's there in Australian and New Zealand's kind of sense of guilt about what's happened to
你完全可以理解为什么当时的人会那样想：那些留着胡子、带着宝剑的人出现了，摧毁了他们视为理所当然的一切。而这种关于哥伦布的视角在70年代、80年代到90年代加速发展、变得更加显著的原因之一，我认为部分是因为周年纪念引发了关注，但也是因为美国民权运动所提供的视角，该运动以黑人美国人为核心。当然，这种影响向外扩散了，因为白人欧洲人对世界的某些部分做出了在哥伦布发现新世界之后随之发生的事情——这种思想体现在反对南非种族隔离的运动中，体现在澳大利亚和新西兰对那里原住民遭遇的负罪感中。
the indigenous peoples there. And there's this feeling that what happens with Columbus is expressive of a trend that has lasted centuries and is kind of enduring into the 21st century. But the counter argument to that is that Columbus is getting grief for a lot of things that he personally, you know, things that happened long after he was dead. So a good example of this is, well, the trend now generally is to see Columbus as a villain. And a good early example of that is from Howard Zinn, his People's History of the United States, you know, overtly Marxist history, very successful though, you know, very popular among students and so on. He says absolutely explicitly Columbus's legacy was, and I quote, conquest, slavery, death.
并且人们有一种感觉，即哥伦布身上发生的事情体现了一种持续了几个世纪并延续到21世纪的趋势。但与之相对的观点是，哥伦布为很多他个人并未做过的事情——在他死后很久才发生的事情——背了黑锅。一个很好的例子是，现在普遍的趋势是将哥伦布视为一个恶棍。而这方面一个较早的例子来自霍华德·津恩（Howard Zinn）的《美国人民的历史》，这是一部公开的马克思主义历史著作，尽管非常成功，但在学生等群体中很受欢迎。他非常明确地指出，哥伦布的遗留物是——我引用他的话说——“征服、奴役、死亡”。
And if you look at any, if you Google Columbus and that sort of American news website or something, so I got a quote from Vox, 2015. Christopher Columbus, in whose name children are off school and mail is not delivered today, was a homicidal tyrant who initiated the two greatest crimes in the history of the Western Hemisphere, the Atlantic slave trade and the American Indian genocide. And I think actually both of those statements are wrong. To say that Columbus
如果你看任何……如果你在谷歌上搜索哥伦布和那种美国新闻网站之类的东西，我从Vox网站2015年的一篇文章里摘录了一段话：“克里斯托弗·哥伦布，这个让孩子们今天不用上学、邮政服务今天停止派送的人，是一个凶残的暴君，他挑起了西半球历史上的两大罪行：跨大西洋奴隶贸易和美洲印第安人种族灭绝。”而我认为，这两句话其实都是错误的。要说哥伦布
initiated the Atlantic slave trade, to me, is to miss the fact that people in the Atlantic were already trading slaves. And it's from that milieu that Columbus comes. So the Portuguese, for example, were already shipping slaves from West Africa, back to Lisbon, to Seville, to their islands in the Atlantic, decades before Columbus. The fact he didn't begin it doesn't alter the fact that he was complicit. But I'm not disputing that, Tom. I'm not saying that he wasn't involved in it. But in a sense, to say, well... He's not the founder of it, though.
开启了跨大西洋奴隶贸易，在我看来，这是忽略了一个事实，即大西洋地区的人们当时已经在进行奴隶贸易了。哥伦布正是在这种背景下诞生的。例如，早在哥伦布之前几十年代，葡萄牙人就已经在将西非的奴隶运回里斯本、塞维利亚以及他们在加勒比海的岛屿上了。他没有发起这一贸易，并不改变他同谋的事实。我并不否认这一点，汤姆。我并不是说他没有参与其中。但在某种意义上，要说……不过他并不是奠基人。
No, he's not. But what happened in the Canary Islands, I mean, that is a kind of genocidal program that had begun in the early 15th century. Not deliberately genocidal, though. What the Spanish want is a workforce, and if people resist, they kill them. Now, the effect is genocidal. We would look at that and we would say, this is terrible, but it's not a deliberate project. Let's wipe all these people out. But I think that what has darkened Columbus's reputation is the fact that the criticisms that were made of him in his own lifetime for what he was doing to the Indians, it was seen as being a terrible thing. And that involved both the sense that they were being wiped out in enormous numbers. Peter Martyr says this,
不，他不是。但在加那利群岛发生的事情，我的意思是，那是一种始于15世纪初的种族灭绝计划。不过，并非故意要种族灭绝。西班牙人想要的是劳动力，如果有人反抗，他们就会杀死他们。现在，其结果确实是种族灭绝。我们会看到这一点并说，这太可怕了，但这并不是一个蓄意的项目，不是为了“把这些人全杀光”。但我认为，抹黑哥伦布声誉的是这样一个事实：在他生前，人们就因他对印第安人所做的事情而对他进行了批评，当时这被认为是一件极其糟糕的事。这既包括他们被大批消灭的事实——彼得·马蒂尔（Peter Martyr）就这么说过，
it's not just Las Casas. Peter Martyr was saying 200,000 die in that war that he and his brother launched on Hispaniola. And also that they keep sending back slaves to Isabella and she gets more and more cross about it. But in a sense, he is on the wrong side of a debate in Spain that has carried into the present. Yeah. That's why there's a kind of a darkness to his name and his reputation now. Against that, it would be remiss to deny that he is an astonishing figure of epical historical significance, and that he's a man of extraordinary courage, extraordinary charisma, and extraordinary ability. And the scale of what he achieved
不仅仅是拉斯卡萨斯。彼得·马蒂尔说，在他和他兄弟在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛发动的战争中有20万人死亡。还包括他们不断向伊莎贝拉女王运送奴隶，而女王对此越来越生气。但从某种意义上说，他在西班牙的一场辩论中站错了边，而这场辩论一直延续到了今天。是的。这就是为什么他的名字和声誉现在带有一种阴暗色彩。与此相对的是，如果否认他是一个具有划时代历史意义的惊人人物，是一个具有非凡勇气、非凡个人魅力和非凡能力的人，那将是失职的。他所成就的规模
is utterly momentous for good or ill. Even on his second voyage, he's worked out the quickest way to get across the Atlantic. He's cracked the wind scheme. He's cracked the fact that you can get across there if you have the wind in your sails. You don't need to worry about it. He's discovered the difference between true north and magnetic north. He's worked out the fact that the globe isn't a perfect sphere. He's negotiated the incredibly complicated seas of the Caribbean. He's begun to fathom that South America is a continent. I mean, any of these, any of those achievements would- And all of them together. Extraordinary. All of them together. Yeah, he is an astonishing figure.
无论好坏，都是极其重大的。甚至在第二次航行中，他就已经找出了横渡大西洋的最快方法。他破解了风向的秘密。他弄清楚了只要顺风扬帆就能横渡过去。你不需要为此担心。他发现了真北和磁北之间的区别。他计算出地球并不是一个完美的球体。他成功航行并通过了加勒比海极其复杂的海域。他开始领会南美洲是一个大陆。我的意思是，任何这些成就——所有这些成就加在一起。非凡。所有这些成就加在一起。是的，他是一个令人惊叹的人物。
While, you know, not doing them, he's not doing this behind a desk. He's doing it in the middle of a storm, leading men. Yeah, I agree with with you and actually i agree with the what you said before that i mean columbus it's one of those things that if he were in a courtroom i mean i don't ever think history should be conducted as a sort of courtroom trial i don't think um i never like the spectacle of historians sort of sitting in judgment and moral judgment and people in the past but imagine that columbus were in a courtroom and you played back, you know, you had hidden cameras and you played back scenes of his behavior on Hispaniola or on Cuba or on Jamaica. I mean, they would be scenes that would have most people averting their eyes in horror,
而且，你知道的，他做这些可不是坐在办公桌后面。他是在风暴中心，率领着众人在做事。是的，我同意你的看法，实际上我也同意你之前所说的话——我的意思是，哥伦布，这就属于那种如果他在法庭上……我的意思是，我从不认为历史应该像法庭审判那样进行，我不认为……我从来不喜欢历史学家那种居高临下地对过去的人进行审判和道德评判的做派。但假设哥伦布在法庭上，如果你回放……你有隐藏摄像头，回放他在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛、古巴或牙买加的行为场景。我的意思是，那些场景会让大多数人惊恐地别过脸去，
and probably that he wouldn't himself watch with, he'd be embarrassed to have them played back, the pillage, the enslaving, all of that kind of thing. So I definitely don't think there's any way in which you can say Columbus was a saintly man, a man of tremendous virtue. And as you say, the very fact that people at the time are shocked by some of the behavior is the real indictment. It doesn't matter what we think, but it matters what Las Casas and what other people at the time, the friars, some of the, you know, what Queen Isabella or some of these people thought that they thought he was behaving badly. I suppose what you would say is that this isn't just, I mean, Columbus is not a violent man before he sails across the Atlantic. So in other words, there's not some deeply buried homicidal impulse in Columbus.
而且他自己大概也不愿意看这些回放，把那些掠夺、奴役以及所有这类事情重新播放出来会让他感到难堪。所以我绝对不认为你可以说哥伦布是个圣人，是一个拥有巨大美德的人。正如你所说，当时的人们对他的某些行为感到震惊，这才是真正的控诉。我们怎么想并不重要，但拉斯卡萨斯以及当时的其他人——修士们、一些……你知道的，伊莎贝拉女王或其中一些人——他们的想法很重要，他们认为他的行为很恶劣。我想你会说，这不单单是……我的意思是，哥伦布在横渡大西洋之前并不是一个暴力的人。换句话说，哥伦布内心并没有那种深埋的嗜血冲动。
He's behaving as he does. He's a desperate man. He's a desperate man. And he's also coming out of a context in which there are already thousands upon thousands of slaves in the Mediterranean and the Atlantic, in which he has been at the court of the Spanish monarchs during a war, a war that they see as a holy war
他的行为方式是由他的处境决定的。他是一个绝望的人。他是一个绝望的人。而且他的背景是：在地中海和大西洋已经存在成千上万奴隶的社会环境中，他在西班牙君主的宫廷里经历过一场战争，一场他们视为圣战的战争——
against the Moors in Granada, it comes out of a very martial, aggressive culture in which the Genoese play a part of entrepreneurs and fixers for predatory competitive powers, in which the Ottoman Empire is one of the most notable. And I think if you miss that, if you just say, well, Columbus is a villain, end of story, he's greedy and he's violent. If you miss the context, then you miss what makes him tick. And I think all the time he's justifying this to himself, isn't he? I mean, he's always, when he's enslaving people, when he's sending them back, when he's behaving badly, he's agonizing about it and he's writing these letters and he's talking
那是针对格拉纳达的摩尔人的战争。他出身于一种非常尚武、极具侵略性的文化，热那亚人在其中扮演了掠夺性竞争势力的企业主和说客角色，奥斯曼帝国就是其中最著名的例子。如果你忽略了这一点，如果你只是说“好吧，哥伦布是个恶棍，故事结束，他贪婪又残暴”，如果你忽略了这个背景，你就无法理解是什么在驱动着他。而且我认为他一直在为此自我辩解，不是吗？我的意思是，他总是——当他在奴役人们、当他把他们送回国、当他的行为恶劣时——他为此感到痛苦，他写下这些信件，他向
to God about it and he really thinks he's doing the right thing. And he's always framing it in very overtly theologically, biblically infused terms. And I've said it before, I'll say it again. I think one of the recent intellectual trends in the study of history is that for lots of people who no longer count themselves as Christian, maybe not even familiar with the most basic elements of scripture. History has come to serve what scripture used to provide. It provides stories and narratives that enable people to understand what is good and evil. And the story of Columbus is a kind of paradigmatic example of that. And the paradox is that when people arraign Columbus as a satanic figure
上帝倾诉，他真的认为自己在做正确的事。他总是用非常明显的神学、充满圣经色彩的术语来为自己辩护。我以前说过，我还要再说一遍。我认为近年来历史研究中的一个知识趋势是，对于许多不再把自己当作基督徒、甚至可能连最基本的经文要素都不熟悉的人来说，历史已经开始充当过去经文所提供的功能。它提供了故事和叙事，使人们能够理解什么是善，什么是恶。而哥伦布的故事就是其中的一个典型范例。而这里的悖论在于，当人们谴责哥伦布是一个恶魔般的人物、
whose evil has spilled into the present, they're kind of doing what Columbus did, which is to interpret the world and world events and the interplay of great men with geography in theological terms, in overtly moral terms. And whether that's a good or bad thing is perhaps a subject for another podcast. But the moralizing of Columbus is something that Columbus himself, that again, is something that Columbus brought to the new world. It's part of the Columbian exchange. It's true. It's an irony, isn't it, that so much of this debate is driven by the United States, by a country that Columbus didn't settle. And so, well, I was just going to maybe end this episode by saying a book recommendation, which isn't a work of history, but a novel, and not written by a European or by a novelist from the United States, but a Mexican, Carlos Fuentes.
其邪恶蔓延到现世时，他们其实在做着和哥伦布一样的事，那就是用神学的术语、用赤裸裸的道德术语来解释世界、世界事件以及伟人与地理的相互作用。这究竟是好是坏，或许是另一个播客可以探讨的主题。但对哥伦布的道德化审判正是哥伦布本人——这一点再次说明，这是哥伦布带给新世界的东西。它是哥伦布大交换的一部分。确实如此。一个具有讽刺意味的事实是，这场辩论的很大一部分是由美国推动的，是由一个哥伦布并未涉足的国家推动的。所以，嗯，我本来打算在这集的最后推荐一本书，它不是一部历史著作，而是一部小说，而且不是由欧洲人或美国小说家写的，而是由墨西哥人卡洛斯·富恩特斯（Carlos Fuentes）写的。
Oh, yeah. Have you read Terra Nostra? No, I've read The Death of Artemio Cruz of artemia cruz and or the artemia cruz it would be rather and um the old gringo isn't he right the old gringo yeah he did but terra nostra is both his masterpiece and by far his most difficult book so he was inspired to write it by finnegan's wake oh my word but it but it's actually much more well it's infinitely more readable than than finnegan's wake but it's a very great counter well, it's infinitely more readable than Finnegan's Wake. But it's a very great counterfactual story in which Felipe Dos, Philip II, America still hasn't been discovered in his reign.
哦，是的。你读过《人间乐园》（Terra Nostra）吗？没有，我读过《阿尔特米奥·克鲁斯之死》（The Death of Artemio Cruz）和……或者应该说是《阿尔特米奥·克鲁斯》，还有《老远东人》（The Old Gringo），他写过这个对吧？《老远东人》，是的，他写过。但《人间乐园》既是他的杰作，也是他迄今为止最难读的一本书。他写这本书的灵感来自于《芬尼根的守灵夜》。天哪！但实际上它要……嗯，它的可读性比《芬尼根的守灵夜》要高得多。但这是一个非常伟大的反事实故事，在故事中，菲利普二世（Felipe Dos）统治时期的美洲仍然没有被发现。
He's married to Isabel Tudor. So Elizabeth, Elizabeth I. So, you know, they've married. And the discovery of America is made in his reign. And all kinds of kind of weird stuff is going on. So you've got Don Quixote and all kinds of things. But it's a brilliant book that kind of transcends the terms of the debate that we've been talking about. Is it good or evil? Is he a hero or a villain? It's about the kind of overwhelming strangeness of the whole business and it brings it brilliantly alive and
他娶了伊莎贝拉·都铎（Isabel Tudor），也就是伊丽莎白一世。所以，你知道的，他们结婚了。而美洲的发现是在他的统治时期发生的。并且发生了各种各样离奇的事情。你甚至能在里面看到堂吉诃德以及各种各样的人物。但这是一本极好的书，它超越了我们一直在讨论的辩论的框架。它是善还是恶？他是英雄还是恶棍？这本书讲的是整件事情那种压倒性的离奇感，它将这段历史写得生动绝伦，
it's really worth the effort of you know it is a quite a challenging novel but it's really i think worth reading and it kind of sits in the back of my mind as something that provides a kind of framing context for this whole story so the story of columbus the story of Cortez, the Aztecs are kind of key part of the narrative. And I highly recommend that. Oh, well, I like the sound of that. So I'm going to check that out because we will be returning
真的值得你花一番心思去读——它确实是一部相当具有挑战性的小说，但我认为非常值得一读。它一直留在我脑海的深处，为整个故事提供了一种框架背景。所以哥伦布的故事、科尔特斯的故事、阿兹特克人都是叙事中的关键部分。我强烈推荐这本书。哦，听起来很不错。所以我得去看看，因为我们在秋天会回到
to this sort of territory in the autumn because we're planning a little series about the conquest of Mexico. So to some extent, that's what happens next. And again, that's a very dark
这类主题上来，因为我们正计划做一个关于征服墨西哥的小系列。所以在某种程度上，那将是接下来要发生的故事。同样，那是一个非常黑暗
and bloody story, much contested by historians and probably much more complicated than we often imagine. So I suppose we haven't really answered the question, have we Columbus hero or villain? And I think one reason we haven't answered is because ultimately it's a pretty sterile question because there aren't really such things as heroes and villains in history, at least I don't think so. Well, it's a question for theologians. Yeah, I guess so i mean columbus
且血腥的故事，历史学家对此争论不休，可能比我们想象的要复杂得多。所以我想我们并没有真正回答这个问题，对吧？哥伦布是英雄还是恶棍？我想我们没有回答的原因之一是，归根结底这是一个相当没有意义的问题，因为历史上其实并没有真正的英雄和恶棍，至少我是这么认为的。嗯，这是个留给神学家的问题。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，哥伦布
was a very profoundly human complicated difficult person i think it's fair to say some admirable qualities and some definitely less admirable ones and less admirable behavior a man who achieved remarkable things for good and for bad perfect a nicely evasive summation to end our own four voyages through the life and times of Christopher Columbus. So all that remains is to say farewell to my shipmate and we will see you
是一个非常深刻、人性化、复杂且棘手的人，我觉得这样说很公平。他有一些令人钦佩的品质，也有一些绝对不那么令人钦佩的品质以及不那么光彩的行为。他是一个成就了非凡事业的人，无论好坏皆是如此。完美，这是一个恰到好处且巧妙回避的总结，为我们自己对克里斯托弗·哥伦布生平与时代的四次航行画上了句号。所以剩下的就是向我的船员道别，我们下周的
for our next voyage next week. Bye-bye. Adios. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一次航行中见。再见。阿迪奥斯（Adios）。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。